president Trump's deadline for the Iran
nuclear deal is just 11 days away and
Israel is pushing him harder to scrap
the agreement Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu went on primetime TV in Israel
to say that quote Iran lied about
wanting to build nuclear weapons he
showed off alleged documents from Iran's
nuclear program before it signed the
deal three years ago iran's Foreign
Minister mocks Netanyahu on Twitter
writing quote the boy who can't stop
crying wolf is at it again
White House spokesman says this
information provides new and compelling
details about Iran's efforts to develop
missile deliverable nuclear weapons face
nation moderator and senior foreign
affairs correspondent Margaret Brennan
is here Margaret good morning good
morning well the u.s. still believes
that Iran has kept its nuclear program
frozen since that 2015 agreement but
yesterday Israel revealed that it had
obtained new details about the scope and
scale of Iran's past attempts to build a
weapon incriminating blueprints standing
next to intelligence seized by Israeli
spies from a warehouse in Tehran Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu said
it proved that Iran had lied about its
efforts to build a nuclear weapon even
after the deal Iran continued to
preserve and expand its nuclear weapons
know-how for future use Netanyahu wants
the u.s. to pull out of the 2015 deal
which froze Iran's nuclear program in
exchange for sanctions relief
last week the leaders of France and
Germany lobbied President Trump to stick
with it rather than tear up the deal as
promised on the campaign trail
so no of anything it's proven right what
Israel has done today with the news
conference the President must make a
decision by May 12th and yesterday the
president said he may instead choose a
third option craft a new version of the
agreement and order before the 12th
we'll make a decision that doesn't mean
we won't negotiate a real agreement most
of the intelligence Netanyahu cited was
from before the 2015 deal had been
signed and he did not present any
evidence that Iran had violated it
speaking to reporters on board his plane
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo said the
new details do show that Iran has not
been honest about the nature of its past
nuclear research this will
spell out the scope and scale of the
program that they undertook there and
said that so far there does not appear
to be evidence to contradict his
testimony last month that Iran has been
faithful to the deal I've seen no
evidence that they are not in compliance
today but it does contradict Iranian
Foreign Minister Javad Zarif claim on
Face the Nation that Iran's past nuclear
program had been for peaceful purposes
Iran was never racing towards a bomb and
it will not be racing towards a bomb
this morning the IAEA which is the UN's
nuclear watchdog said they had quote no
credible indications of activities in
Iran relevant to the development of a
nuclear explosive device after 2009 in
other words we already knew this right
we're good and given the fact that
policymakers based their policy on the
idea that Iran was lying right who was
this for that was this an audience of
one in donald trump and was it to
convince him or give him backing for
what he might do a bit of both because
he has been lobbied hard by our allies
and partners really remember is not a
signatory in Benjamin Netanyahu the
Prime Minister has long advocated
against it they want to see the u.s. be
more muscular in the region in other
words look at more military options
rather than go through with this
diplomatic deal but it was an
all-english presentation it was
multimedia it appealed so many of the
things that the president likes in these
presentations and he used TV clips as
well so it spoke to the president's
language and in some ways may help
provide him cover for a sleight-of-hand
where they don't fully blow up the deal
but perhaps the president gets to say
he's going to fix it do you think
there's a relationship between fixing
doing whatever's gonna happen in the
Iran deal and this emerging agreement
not agreement or whatever with North
Korea
well the Trump administration pushes
back hard against that because yes a
whole lot of part not partners in this
deal say how can we partner with you
again when you're gonna break your own
word and how can anyone agree to sign on
if you're gonna do that but at the same
time the administration says this is
totally different that North Korea
really is concerned about maintaining
Kim jong-un's power and if he gets
basically a high enough price it'll be
good enough for them but the president
also thinks that this has but
his argument that if you push hard you
can get the other side to agree to a new
term a new deal but so far Iran has said
no takers here Margaret thank you